yeah I read a lot of things that God
kept you here to help others but I don't
know why hit me I can't kill you he
talked to me he talked to me
my name is Richard oven Overton I am a
hundred and nine years old
stillwall I still talk and I still drive
[Music]
I just got my license renewed this year
yet they give you a kiss
everything they're given our passion
I feel good going on driving
I like to drive myself cause other drug
they drive crazy
I am always wore to read
I went in the Army at 1940 making mo
braver stronger I could see could ever
do is opening here not a lot going hasty
no you don't know boy yeah you see a
soldier would have gone y'all see him
turn around go back this way
they go side way but he ain't gonna come
around go back okay I can put his airs
you ain't gonna go back there yet when
you go in there USA we're dodging got me
now see you got to take care of your
time to go
hey buddy don't get you if you take your
time to go
that brother going over you hey I think
I hit you go man a killer but God you
want to keep you alive
[Music]
it wasn't it wasn't good but we had to
go
[Music]
I built my house and that's 45 that's
where I've been ever since
it's a nice face of the earth
[Music]
yeah I'm happy with my own I saw what I
need I bought one thing I will use that
one thing I was about one thing go buy a
nut and go buy a new I've got a crook
after any run just like I wanted so I
just keep it
[Music]
but I don't fool with a credit card
never be everything are you paid cash
for it I got 50 cents a day that's way
back in but I lived at that I was ever
staying with nickel and dime three cents
I meant when the man get your face
forward like that
Epping it up I take a pink car Danny
heard he gonna get a car we know what a
car would with later back we know what's
come to town much my first car was a
little boy
t-ball forward that didn't front cranky
you remember him car no you weren't born
their way no I know you would
[Music]
I just said in smoke some time twelve
cigars a day maybe sometime Monette
[Music]
anybody share what you smoke them for I
guess I guess it makes you feel better
[Music]
but you came in here just to go ahead
and just go to that letter going
forget about swathi sorry no taste to it
just make you cold
I'm going to health away every time I
get up in the morning that cat sitting
there waiting either go to V it sometime
they're sitting up there waiting because
they want to get to supper and then they
want to go to be
[Music]
but you don't feed a cat too much cause
he will eat a rat
[Music]
I have those casting to keep me happy
I tell a drill a team habit I want to
see my cats alimony
I wake up one o'clock or you know wake
up it two or three any time I wake up I
just get up
get me a cup of coffee sometime I drink
I broke up the coffee in the morning
this morning I drank about that much
whiskey I love me up a fish corn and
soup I love soup
a lot of people don't like soup
don't break me up but I've been drinking
milk for over writing all my life and
ice cream I eat ice cream every night it
makes me happy
he put butter for cars you're bowing to
buying and you buy butter pecan
it is the old tinnitus anybody died
there Maureen
[Music]
you
Church is a wonderful place
lovely place
[Music]
keeps me going
makes me feel good I think that helps me
push myself at all
[Music]
you're lonesome eh too
you know how to live better I'll treat
people
[Music]
we don't have old and I just say someone
asked somebody else to do and singing I
know that you're saying it beautiful
[Music]
Church is just for everybody
[Music]
you have to go for one person that's
yourself
good have a speck July but you got
living
[Music]
they make you feel better to have it
first man you're like this
we get along real nice though he 91
years old you know I'm kind of 9
[Music]
yeah we goes to the hospital to see
people go to the grocery store we go
shopping sometime and register
stretching and take a different place is
she just a nice person
yep we have fun together
[Music]
I've seen large large live
[Music]
I'm still living good and suffer nothing
gets what I want
sure and she live it all right
[Music]
you
[Music]
don't give up you're through you just
found yourself I am I'm giving you some
my secret to a long life if you ever use
it if you don't use that you're better
off not coming got ya yet and I don't
know when I'll come here and I don't
know where I'm going
you eat dear one I was going we going I
[Music]
may give out but I never you up
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]